Great news. We're receiving more updates on how the
immigration reform in this 2,024 will look like.
And in this video
we're going to explore four of those.
First of all,
the government is going to aim to unify the immigration
criteria used by the different immigration offices.
As of today,
as you may already know,
depending on the immigration office where you go,
the criteria for obtaining your residency may change.
And this is about to be modified with this new reform.
Second, simplification.
What the measure is also aiming at
is to reduce the amount of residents permits
and unify as much as possible
to different residents permits figures.
This will mean that some residences will be eliminated
and will be unified into just a few residents permits.
Also, with this aim of simplification,
the government aims to reduce the amount of renewals
required. So,
for example,
we don't know yet how this will work,
but for example,
one possible measure would be to
increase the initial duration of residency cards
from one year to three
or similar. Third,
the modification of the residency regime for
relatives of Spanish national.
Today this is a bit tricky
because many relative of Spanish nationals
come to Spain under the
a general immigration regime,
others under the European regime.
And this can be a bit tricky
for foreigners to understand.
What this 2,024 measure will do
is to maybe create a separate.
A new regime for those relatives of Spanish national
So coming to Spain with them is much easier
and straightforward.
And fourth, easier access to the Spanish labour market.
What does this mean?
Well, first of all,
that the shortage occupational list will be amplified
according to the original
needs of each of the different locations in Spain.
This will include possibly
more job opportunities for foreigners to come to Spain.
So this is a measure created to attract
foreigner workers to Spain.
And specifically,
what the measure
is intended to do
is create more job positions
for the construction sector,
which is really demanding in Spain,
and will include more positions under it.
So stay tuned,
we're going to be posting
all the updates of this new reform tour for 2,024.
For that, make sure to follow us.